fears of food shortages prompting many
to stack up on supplies
uk flights banned from dozens of
countries
but prime minister boris johnson is
trying to reassure everyone that
everything is under control
hoping to have the situation resolved
after speaking to france's president
emmanuel macron
it's very very important for uh not just
for
people's morale but it's also totally
realistic that we have every reason
to be extremely hopeful about
this country's ability to bounce back
next year
from kobed yet outside on the streets
on the borders there's a very different
picture or anything to be hopeful about
the announcement by the government of a
new more transmissible strain of the
corvid virus has concerned france
europe and many other countries the new
variant was identified in the uk in
september
and by last week it accounted for more
than 60 percent of culverd 19 cases in
london it's thought to be
about 40 to 70 percent more
transmissible but scientists say
that it doesn't appear to be more deadly
and there's no evidence to suggest that
the new vaccine will be less effective
against it
variants of the virus have also been
identified in spain
belgium australia italy the netherlands
and south africa
instead of infecting one or two people
when you're talking or breathing near
them
you might be infecting three or four
okay so this seems to be
how the various spreading further and
faster so it's not spreading in a
different way
it's just there's more of it spreading
to more people who are nearby
boris johnson says he hopes freight
transport issues will be resolved soon
and he's working with his european
partners to find a solution
yet there are only 10 days left for the
uk deadline to leave europe totally
there's still no trade deal the
disruption the uk is experiencing now
a possible prelude of what's to come if
they leave europe without a deal
assad beg al-jazeera london